il y a de plus en plus de personnes
seules dans les grandes villes c'est en
tout cas ce qu'indique très clairement
la dernière enquête de l'ined l'institut
national de la démographie dans ces
grandes villes une personne sur quatre
vit seule qu'elle soit divorcé âgé ou
célibataires ce chiffre important révèle
un véritable phénomène de société aux
conséquences que nous présente
maintenant dominique torrès et
jean-marie lequertier mois de mariage
plus de divorces les français dit de
plus en plus seule une personne sur 4 à
paris et non pas tous le coeur en pierre
changement d'attitude de vie de moeurs
certains entrent dans le célibat comme
naguère en religion trois catégories de
célibataires aux motivations différentes
les jeunes les vieux les divorcés
divorcer ce père de famille est à
présent un apôtre fervents du foyer à
une personne vous faites des repas pour
vous tout seul
élaborée comme ça absolument offre tout
à fait régulièrement systématiquement
quotidiennement la tablette un grand
plaisir dont je n'ai pas envie de me
priver de manger au restaurant des
autres forces e mail au moins 80 % de
fois je m'en sens
[Musique]
vous faites salle sans absolument tout
de plus en plus de choses je dirais même
qu'aujourd'hui je ne comprends même pas
comment on permet au cinéma avec
quelqu'un ou comment opérer au concert
avec quelqu'un ou comment on perd le
l'opéra avec quelqu'un c'est à dire ses
désirs disponibilité permanente d'être
avec les autres je suis pas un ours du
tout j'aime les autres mais je les
aborder avec le sentiment que je suis
libre disponible de les aborder nouvelle
clientèle nouveaux besoins donc nouveaux
produits l'économie se met à l'heure des
célibataires on vend de plus en plus de
boîtes de conserves d'un quart c'est à
dire petit tout petit et de portions
pour client seul on peut même acheter
des plats raffinés pour se délecter face
à face avec soi même
prenez souvent des plats seule une
personne oui très souvent je suis je vis
tout seul j'ai une vie très active
donc je trouve ça vraiment très pratique
et en plus c'est très beau plateau repas
hamburger frites et coca cola l'air du
temps s'est mis à la restauration rapide
aujourd'hui en mange souvent vite et
seul
célibataire ça arrive souvent des deux
seuls marchés ça du tout c'est triste de
manger dans un restaurant sol ou est-ce
que
alors que l'annoncé du décès alors
qu'orange france n'aurait pu ensemble
autrement ça vous arrive de manger dans
des restaurants si je puis dire mais ça
je te l'expérience quelques fois et
depuis on ne sait vraiment trop triste
oui les jeunes restent célibataires plus
longtemps qu'avant mais avec peut-être
l'espoir secret de la rencontre qui va
tout changer
[Musique]